Marty wisely we have
to tense your body while that is going
to make sure your mobile is going to
take
more of your
you simple man
and your shoulder pressure is going to
test for your mobility
if you don't have
we use embracing angle
kidding yourself it's gonna be more
exposed
and also
a lot of you have not reconciled your
fear of pain and so you have now arrived
in South care nor do you have the skill
on how to neutralize the
the young energy of noggin so you can me
that's what you're working on all that
stuff okay so we do the pins of
evolution change we think this is still
a projection so you might find it more
difficult for especially those who were
running backwards bent over
you should fill the in space so he can
stand up if he wants
that's going to expose
when the arm right
he's taller than you
so you can stand up
just work and get reps in
[Music]
so he's still learning a zucchini
concepts unusual in the way Nagas are to
understand modern understands it as if
then he understands his new Kimia 20 and
the beginner is always doing what's as
if ritual in his if-then mentality
allows me a train daughter so I still
have the same task of the technician of
the Senate okay so we go he's supposed
to push that's his only rule then after
that so I come here I give him the cues
you see in his body then it's not
whether he wants to stand up for God you
see he only has two choices take it up
or get taken over that's it which is
fine you take that
wait no now you can't do instruction I
just changed it'll be more pain
reference it'll be easy for him so you
took that one half time techniques dildo
but more because you do is rinse
[Music]
instruction every time you get pull your
giving
[Music]
so when you do your as this ritual they
start responding to that okay it's the
safety you live like people are late you
act as if they're not they stop being
one